[Music]
patrick is with us in
nebraska kearney nebraska hi patrick how
are you
hey guys hey rachel dave how's it going
y'all good how can we help
so we're my wife and i we're on baby
step two
um we just actually sold our car back at
the dealership
got rid of that dang thing um we just
paid off all of our our credit cards and
um we're going full fledge into our
student loans
with as you guys say gazelle intensity
good for you
that's awesome and and uh so my question
is
i know baby step one is have an
emergency savings of a thousand dollars
i'm self-employed
and so we would feel more comfortable
having a little more of a pillow there
so like uh
anywhere from three to five k and we
just wanted to know
what your recommendation on that would
be obviously that's against the baby
steps but uh being self-employed you
feel like it might be a little bit of a
different scenario
yeah i mean you you carry a little bit
more risk because of that
self-aware what do you do what industry
are you in
uh i'm a personal trainer okay do you
have months you make zero
uh no okay so what's your worst month
uh probably about 3k
okay um i'd stay with a thousand
now when you get to baby step three
and you look at the three to six months
i might have the six month
side because your emergency fund but the
the point of baby step one is not to
have enough
by the way if one thousand is not enough
three thousand is probably not enough
either
right you're right because whatever i
mean whatever's going to come up is
going to come up
and if it's got to do if it's related to
you being self-employed
3 000 1 000 it's not it's going to
matter so
the point is it's not enough it's just
to catch the little stuff the alternator
that goes out on the car or that kind of
thing yeah because if you guys have a
big emergency that comes up a medical
issue or something that's when we say
pause the baby steps and take you know
take care of that so i mean it's that
thousand dollars
but again that's not related to being
self-employed the only thing that's
being related to self-employed is
irregular income
yeah and this is a and patrick your
question is self-employed or not though
like this is a question we get a lot
because people get nervous
with a thousand which i understand like
i get that i'm a mom three kids and i'm
like
whoo if it was that thousand dollars but
part of it is having that that urgency
to get through it quickly and then the
other deal is like hey if something
comes up then then you pause
the debt snowball figure it out and then
play it back again yeah
yeah because you're still making an
income it's still coming in yeah
somebody inside the building was
looking at something um uh the other day
that like dave ramsey's out of date he
doesn't understand a thousand dollars is
not enough and i'm like
dude there's never been a time that a
thousand dollars was enough
i mean 30 years ago when i started
talking about this third thousand
dollars running enough then
so um you know that that's you know it's
not like
it's not like i didn't keep up with the
times or something i remember the uh
writing love your life not theirs this
would have been this would probably have
been
five years ago it was right before a
million so yeah five six years ago
and i so badly wanted to change baby
step one to one month's income do you
remember that
i came in i was like listen we could
change the baby steps
you looked at me like i had three eyes
you were like no we're not changing the
baby steps i've been teaching this for
30 years i was like yeah okay
and it still works and it still works so
that i get it patrick i totally
understand yeah
is what needs to drive you guys the only
time a thousand dollars feels like a lot
is if you've never had a thousand
dollars yeah i mean that's the only time
it would feel like it was a lot
and honestly forty percent of americans
can't cover a 400
emergency yeah so for half of america
having a thousand dollars
is like oh well i actually have savings
in the bank i don't even want to talk
about half of america today
tell us tell us you've ever seen